bastien fogiel vous avez invité sur
votre plateau l'humoriste avait il ment
jamais lé tabou bravo d'un lieu en mieux
le service public
alors on le terrorisme monsieur
internationale
mais là c'est aux femmes et nos enfants
ont trouvé judicieux d'en assurer la
présence et que jamais debout sur ce
plateau est une provocation
insupportable à un acte auquel il vous
faudra répondre monsieur fogiel s'est un
peu d'improvisation
alors c'est vrai que même la vénitie
plus cibourienne de plus rires marc
olivier fogiel il voit tout de suite
qu'un gros malaise
ça c'est un des plus gros malaise à la
télé et oeri voilà on est à la limite de
plein de trucs parce que je dis ça
dépend de ce que raconte dieudonné sur
scène six et des sketchs que moi il ya
des sketch de dieudonné je regrette rien
fait hurler de rire
après quand il est dans son délire
antisémite ça me fait pas rire mais on
n'est plus dans l'humour père il est
devenu un délire antisémite l ai pas je
suis paraît difficile à trancher reçu
plein de sketches plus personne ne sait
ce que sera d'accord et au lieu de venir
oui car je suis pas d'accord avec ça
parce que tout à l'heure j'ai parlé d'un
humour obsessionnel bon à la limite
dieudonné il s'arrête à ce qu'il a fait
là franchement je veux dire de qu'un
autre va faire le musulman lente il va
faire alors encore une fois je dis ne
prenons pas les choses premier degré
prendre un peu de hauteur mais le
problème c'est que dieu donne il a
choisi une cible c'est ce qu'ils lâchent
jamais et plus que ça il se présente à
des élections
c'est un combat politique il présente
des élections et d'effacer le contenu de
ses sketchs pour le mettre dans des
tracts électoraux la sepronat ya un
problème
le mec il a décidé de franchir le
rubicon n'ya pas aller au devant des
citoyens tout devant le suffrage
universel pour dire voilà ce que j'aime
combat j'aime combat s'effectue au mal
le proche orient machette ou mais c'est
son droit d'avoir ce combat là mais à un
moment donné est ce que tu dois le
matérialiser sous le sceau de l'humour
un moment donné puis sous le sceau de la
politique à un autre moment qu'est ce
qui est de l'humour
qu'est-ce que de la politique est ce que
tu dis c'est plus clair du tout si ça je
dois lancer le dernier
ça le problème des journées c'est qu'il
s'est perdu au